- [Kelly] Nice to see you in person.
- Yeah.
- [Kelly] Nice to see you again.
- Much nicer isn't it, to do it in person?
- [Kelly] Yes, it's a little less awkward.
How are your girls?
- They're great, yeah.
- Yeah?
- I'm missing them at the moment.
I've been away from them for 10 days
- [Kelly] Oh
- And we have like, a two week rule.
- I was gonna say, do you have a rule?
- Yeah, yeah. Two weeks.
I've only broken it once,
so I get back just in time.
So, yeah.
- [Kelly] Yeah
Do they still think of
you as like a funny dad,
like a cool dad?
Or are you kind of annoying?
Have you gotten to that stage?
- I'm not sure. You know, I
guess cause we've had three,
so you get three chances
at like, trying to continue
the idea that you're funny.
- [Kelly] Yeah, that you're cool.
- So you try all the same
material out with each one.
My, my whole thing is...
which worked when they
were at a particular age,
and now it doesn't work at all,
is I can't be around a
banana and not pick it up
and go, "hello?"
(Kelly and audience laugh)
Like, it's not remotely funny,
- It's kind of funny
- But I'm- it's not, no
- I'm 39 and I am gonna do it tonight.
- But listen, I'm 39 too,
listen, it won't work.
What age are your kids?
They won't find it funny.
- Well, it will work for- my
son will laugh. He's five.
- Yeah, our five-year-old started
rolling her eyes at it for me.
- Boys are a little- they advance slower.
- [Jamie] Yeah.
- He's gonna laugh.